since the reveal of phase four of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and the
upcoming reveal of phase 5 fans are
getting really excited about the future
of the MCU however fans are truly bummed
out that there's no longer going to be a
Tony Stark and Iron Man in the MCU how's
it going everybody it's Warren and just
like everybody else I too am sad that we
will no longer have a Tony Stark Iron
Man in the MCU however there may be a
little bit of hope as there are reports
coming around stating that we may not
have seen Tony Stark for the last time
in the MCU and that he could actually
pop up in a future MCU movie as an AI so
let's break down this report and talk
about the movie that he could appear in
and why it makes perfect sense for him
to return as an AI in this film real
quick if you'd like a chance to win in
Xbox one or ps4 be sure to subscribe to
my channel like this video and comment
below with your favorite superhero or
villain so you can enter my giveaway I'm
picking a new winner at 500,000
subscribers so at the end of Avengers in
game some characters got successors
Steve Rogers gave his shield and the
mantle of Captain America to Sam and now
Sam is the new Captain America in the
MCU but we don't have an immediate Iron
Man successor Morgan Stark his daughter
is way too young and Harley keiner is
still probably too young as well so it
doesn't look like we'll be getting an
actual Iron Man any time soon however
there has been lately a lot of talk
about an iron heart movie coming to the
MCU and based off of everything that is
going around it seems like it's only a
matter of time until this movie happens
especially considering the direction
that Marvel is going possibly developing
an a force and according to a report
from we got this covered comm Marvel
Studios does plan on developing an Iron
Heart movie and again according to we
got this covered calm their sources tell
them that Tony Stark could return as an
artificial intelligence for Iron Heart
in an Iron Heart movie this would
essentially make Tony Stark a sort of
Jarvis or Friday for Iron Heart this way
Tony Stark could in some way remain in
the MCU now the death of Tony Stark was
a monumental moment in the MCU and is
not something that Marvel is going to
take lightly to underplay or make less
monumental so if this does happen it
will most likely not happen until years
down the road presumably after phase 4
and after phase 5 perhaps Marvel Studios
could give Morgan Stark enough time to
grow up and avenge
go on to take on the Iron Heart mantel
or could Sheree possibly become The Next
Iron Heart we already know that she's a
genius and is an expert at
nanotechnology and weaponry and given
the massive success of Black Panther
perhaps Sheree could take on the mantle
of iron heart after black panther 2 and
it makes sense that whoever becomes the
next iron heart or Iron Man would have
an AI that is Tony Stark Tony Stark is
the original Iron Man
so whoever takes on the mantle of the
next Iron Man will definitely remember
him and Tony did already upload a
message that we saw at the end of
Avengers in game well who's to say that
he didn't somehow upload a part of his
consciousness into a computer program
much like we saw Zola do in Captain
America the Winter Soldier but again
this would be years down the road and
this report does not say that it is
confirmed but what would you think if
Tony Stark made a return to the MCU as
an artificial intelligence for the next
Iron Heart let me know your thoughts in
the comments down below also don't
forget to comment with your favorite
superhero or villain like this video and
subscribe to my channel so you can enter
my giveaway and stay up to date on
everything relating to the MCU
also don't forget to follow me on
Twitter and Instagram and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof